[Musique]
bonsoir
alors ici à ma place ce soir normalement
c'était une note
je crois qu'il est là j'ai fait beaucoup
et nab devait prendre la parole pour
raconter son histoire racontée le
travail que représente l'intégration en
france quand on est un mineur isolé et
en plus migrants mon dernière minute il
a changé d'avis il m'a expliqué il
souhaite maintenant avoir une vie
invisible l'a entendue par la normale
entre guillemets il souhaite qu'on ne le
voit pas plus que les autres pas plus
que nous donc après lui c'est moussa qui
a dit ok je me jette d'ailleurs j'y vais
moi je voudrais parler de
l'acculturation donc déjà il m'a appris
ce que c'était que l'acculturation à ce
mix entre la culture du pays d'accueil
et la culture du immigrants qui arrivent
donc c'était le message qui voulez vous
portez en tout cas tour à tour tous les
jeunes qui ont eu envie à un moment
donné de venir prendre la parole et qui
finalement ont eu peur et n'ont pas osé
c'était toujours dans l'idée que vous
les comprenez mieux pour avoir envie de
les rencontrer et d accueillir tous se
sont rétractés parce que tous ont eu
peur parce que être mineurs isolés
migrants
c'est pas simple là beaucoup de censure
associés à ce statut c'est très
compliqué donc voilà c'est moi qui
prends la place ce soir c'est une lourde
responsabilité j'ai très peur de trahir
leur parole j'ai très peur de dire des
bêtises qui puisse les mettre en danger
j'espère être au plus juste et pour ça
je vais essayer d'être au plus près de
moi meme je sui corim
je suis actuellement éducatrice
l'accompagnent une trentaine de jeunes
mineurs isolés ou majeurs isolé en
provenance d'afrique
auparavant j'ai fait une mission lors de
laquelle j'ai rencontré enoch qui lui
est erythréen suite au démantèlement de
la jungle de calais voilà j'aime mon
travail j'aime ma mission je voudrais
aller au delà de de ce que j'ai à faire
auprès d'eux et je voudrais vous donner
envie de prendre votre part dans cet
accueil plutôt que donner des jugements
critiqué la politique
on a tous à faire dans ce sens là si on
veut et on va devoir le faire bien vivre
ensemble de manière harmonieuse donc le
premier message qui leur semblent
importants que je vous porte c'est le
fait qu'ils n'ont pas choisi d'être ici
pour aucun d'eux aucun migrant décide de
laisser sa famille ses racines sa
culture ses danses ses champs juste pour
le plaisir du voyage et du périple et
dieu celle périple les médias on parle
de plus en plus ils sont là ils n'ont
pas choisi même si on les voit déambuler
de plus en plus sur les trottoirs on
voit ces jeunes ados un peu agaçant
parce qu'ils sont noirs et en plus ils
sont super bien habillé portable en main
basket dernier cri ces jeunes n'ont pas
choisi et non pas choisi d'être ici ils
sont partis tous pour des raisons de
survie
ils étaient tous en danger soit parce
que leur pays est en guerre
soit parce comme enoch son pays est en
dictature donc quand on est un jeune
garçon il vaut mieux s'en aller vite
si on veut pas devenir possession de
l'armé pour toute la vie pour les autres
ils sont partis pour des histoires plus
méconnus nous tout ce qui relève
quelquefois leur culture ou de leur
religion et qui font qu'à un moment
donné ils ne sont plus désirable et ils
sont en danger de mort je vais pas
donner de détails pour ne pas rentrer
dans leur intimité jeu
je voudrais pas aller là où je n'ai pas
à aller seule pourrait parler de tout ça
mais il ya bien en tête et cette
conscience qu'aucun d'eux n'a choisi
quelle que soit leur provenance ils sont
là dans un non choix et c'est important
de se rendre compte de ça parce que le
périple est difficile de par sa route la
traverser la méditerranée c'est juste
horrible
beaucoup de jeunes me rapportent qu'ils
se sont cru mort il me l'expliquent de
cette manière on était au mieux des
corps morts au milieu des gens qui
étaient en train de se noyer et on se
sentait plus de la matière on se sentait
autre chose peut-être de l'énergie mais
en tout cas on a cru qu'on était morts
et c'est seulement quand on a touché le
sol européen
quand on a eu la chance d'avoir le
treuil d'un hélicoptère qui est descendu
un gros bateau qui passait par là où un
aîné qui nous a filé un bout de chambre
à air ou un morceau de bois du bateau
qui coule eh eh bien on renaît à partir
du moment où on touche le sol ferme mais
pas avant avant on est mort comme tout
le monde
donc ces jeunes ont aussi ce message a à
vous transmettre le message de gens
éveillés ce sont des jeunes des gens
éveillés je sais pas comment vous dire
mieux ça nous tous on est souvent dans
cette quête spirituelle qui consiste à
laisser mourir notre ego au profit de la
rencontre de notre âme et biens n'ont
pas choisis l'ont vécu c'est du vécu
il l'attendait pas et ne cherchez pas
c'est quelque chose qui est venu les
chercher ils se sont retrouvés dans le
néant
face à leurs âmes et c'est tout ça qui
portent avec eux et ça mérite vraiment
qu'on les rencontre parce qu'ils ont
beaucoup à nous apprendre dans ce sens
là n'ont plus peur de la mort ils savent
vivre l'instant présent
ils savent apprécier chaque petite chose
et surtout ils savent qu'ils ne sont pas
maîtres de leur sort
même s'ils ont beaucoup de choses à
mettre en place dans leurs actions
lutte pour les papiers administratifs
pour l'intégration et ils savent qu'il
ya autre chose de bien plus grands qui
les dépasse killy donnera
l'aboutissement d'histoire donc qu'ils
ont cette espèce de lâcher prise dont on
rêve tous et dont on aurait tous tous
besoin est ils sont en capacité nous le
transmettre juste dans la rencontre
je vous assure et m'ont appris
énormément je vous souhaite de les
rencontrer je leur souhaite vous
rencontrer
pas n'importe comment mais dans cet
espace dahmane de choeur à coeur
au delà des embûches de lego et de nos
personnages créés de toutes pièces qui
font qu'on se retrouve souvent en
opposition en conflit ont des
hiérarchies dans des luttes de pouvoir
ardent des vieilles blessures non
l'espace de rencontrer pour nous tous
aussi d'ailleurs le meilleur des espaces
de rencontre c'est celui de l'âme et du
coeur et ces jeunes m'ont appris cet
espace si magnifique où tous on élit
mêmes humains de cette terre qui avons
envie de vivre ensemble d'évoluer
ensemble de construire ensemble et nous
avons à le faire et nous allons devoir
le faire parce que quel que soit ce que
vous pensez quel que soit ce qu'on nous
rapporte je vous assure que les flux
migratoires ne cessent pas chaque jour
c'est des centaines c'est des milliers
de gens qui passent les frontières parce
qu'ils n'ont pas d'autres choix
au même titre que les plantes et les
animaux entre n'étant survie on se
pousse plus loin c'est juste normal on
peut pas leur reprocher ça voyez donc
cette richesse de ce mélange qui est
impossible à éviter qui est riche et qui
vaut la peine
e.on cette dimension spirituelle à nous
transmettre à nous apprendre un beau
chemin et nous peut-être avant
toute cette confiance en l'humain alors
redonné parce qu'ils ont perdu sur leur
périple ils ont été trahis maintes et
maintes fois par même les plus gentils
en façade
donc ils ont perdu cette confiance en
l'homme et nous pouvons très facilement
leur redonner confiance en l'humain en
osant s'approcher d'eux coeur ouvert si
c'est pas tout à fait ouverts ils vont
vous aider vous allez voir et puis leur
redonner possession de ce que les
politiques oublient de prendre en compte
la politique rempli sa mission
normalement mais en général c'est fait
les besoins fondamentaux sont assouvi
voir manger être abritées mais je suis
convaincu je suis sûr que vous le savez
aussi c'est pas suffisant quand on est
un humain de vivre dans ces conditions
n'a d'autres besoins des besoins
d'intégrité des besoins d'autonomie de
ce autonome et des besoin d'exprimer son
soissons - intérieur avec ses dons ses
goûts ses valeurs bien la difficulté
pour tous ces gens en fait c'est qu'en
arrivant ici
la première des choses qui leur est
demandé c'est d'oublier tout ça on n'a
pas le droit d'avoir envie d'être
historien prof d'histoire quand on est
mineur isolé migrants et qu'on veut
faire des études on n'a pas le droit non
plus d'avoir des grandes capacités parce
que tous à la france en a pas vraiment
besoin
on a besoin des métiers du bâtiment à la
limite cuisine
service mécanique bref ces gens n'ont
pas le droit d'habiter ce qu'ils sont
dommage parce qu'ils sortent justement
de cet éveil spirituel et il pourrait
exploser avec leur potentiel ça pourrait
être assez incroyable malheureusement on
sape un peu tout ça à partir du moment
où on arrive dans cet accueil on doit
mettre tout ça de côté et moi je leur
souhaite et je les encourage et je vous
demande de les encourager à votre tour
si vous les rencontrez à rester centré
avec eux mêmes malgré tout même si
officiellement tout ça ça n'a pas le
droit vraiment d'exister leur culture
leur goût essayez de les aider et c'est
ce que j'essaie de faire au quotidien
à ne pas oublier tout ça leur leurs
racines c'est sûr point s'appuient tous
cette sécurité affective
ce sur quoi s'appuient tous aussi ils
n'ont plus rien de tout ça la seule
chose qu'il leur reste c'est leur dieu
et mon intuition profonde et que ça
n'est pas suffisant et peut-être même
dangereux le mot est fort mais je crois
que il faut qu'on puisse s'appuyer les
uns sur les autres
compter les uns sur les autres faire
ensemble et ça pour moi c'est un gage de
monde harmonieux qu on a à construire
tous ensemble c'est le gage d'un monde
de paix c'est mon intuition profonde
voilà donc chez eux sans glisser un peu
tout seul ce soir mais en fait je suis
plein de courage je sais qu'il ya
quelques jeunes ici et c'est à eux de
penser peu va bien et puis y'a moussa
qui est aussi avec moi ici avec un texte
est il écrit beaucoup de textes moussa
et qu'il a souhaité lire et enregistrer
puisqu'il ne souhaitait pas être vu s'il
était venu s'il était venu se serait
probablement capuche et capuche et doit
vous
parce que leur situation administrative
fait qu'ils se sentent toujours en
danger et cette espèce de pot qu'ils
habitent la peau qu'on leur demande de
construire et bien n'ose pas trop la
montre et parce que c'est pas la leur
ils sont habités par ce sentiment de
trahison de leurs croyances de leur
religion de leur culture
cette sensation de triche à avoir à se
déguiser un jeune européen dans l'hyper
consommation et ils ont bien compris
comme tous les jeunes d'ici d'ailleurs
quand on veut se faire une place
on doit passer par là donc je vous
laisse écouter deux minutes moussa avec
un magnifique texte comme il sait bien
le faire
et puis c'est avec lui qu'on terminera
l'hospitalité merci vous donne ok merci
bouleurs utiliser des scieries merci
boulet petit migrants merci pour les
orphelins de guerre paru aussi lente des
zoophiles est là qui nous est devenu
sourire ta qui m'a fait oublier monsieur
ni passé toi tu es des phrases qui
renient l'ensemble des ratés pas qu'ils
accueillent sans compte de la révision
de la race aire d'accueil terre
hospitalière ou matin comme une merde
c'est pas la france qu'ils aiment et sa
population si merveilleuse
grâce à toi j'ai croisé mais par un
sanguin dessins mes frères mes soeurs
perçu ressenti sensation choc hommage où
ça
merci à vous de m'avoir recruté 6
merci à vous d'oser doser la rencontre
et il suffit que vous fassiez la même
chose que vous passiez par vous même et
puis pas besoin de mental il ya pas
besoin de faire de la politique dans
tout ce qui se passe là juste écouter
son coeur
merci
[Applaudissements]